comment ça va ça va et toi ça va
cordialement cordialement va bien ça va
Kevin bonjour internet aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour doubler un film les gars
est-ce que vous êtes contents s'appelle
rachchette et clan moi je suis hyper
heureux moi je savais que ça allait
m'arriver un jour donc je suis pas
content en fait oh le mec rabageois oh
tu Ratchet etclan vous avez sûrement
entendu ce nom qu'est-ce que c'est RET
c'est un jeu qui est sorti sur PS2 en
2002 en 2002 vous savez c'est l'animal
et le robot finalement on peut résumer
ça comme ça exact et ben qu'est-ce qu'on
attend allons-y allons doubler attends
attends viens on mais il est fait
chque C qui lui ouais mais c'est pas
facile
hein bonjour bonjour ah ça te su je vous
ai dit que je connais C Hur parce que
j'ai déjà doublé un film ou pas alors on
va se mettre d'accord tout de suite tu
as doublé un pigeon et un piaf je c je
crois que c'était une mette quand même
arrête de cétait une moette c'est vrai
qu'allons-nous doubler quel personnage
on va doubler on ve savoir finalement
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose bon alors à la tête comme ça je
sais pas toi toi je te vois bien en Brax
en Brax un gros Molos toi par contre je
te vois bien en
Z petit robot un peu su
boule et toicors ah r ça serait pas mal
la après la mouette c'est la bette
[Musique]
merci on a aussi eu un problème sur sur
ce doublage on va pas se mentir on se
respectait pas trop le moindre bruit ça
ça tout tu l'entend exactement et du
coup des fois quand y en a qui commence
à doubler son perso autre qui soit ou
qui je sououv une canette et ça nique
toute la prise trop
stylé trop
stylé quand même tu
viens merci Kevin pour l'interview merci
ça nous a fait plaisir moi j'interprète
Brax c'est un Ranger qui s'occupe un peu
de l'entraînement de des nouveaux
Rangers et c'est kiffant c'est vraiment
un personnage costaud il a une gueule
comme ça il il a des trucs sur la tête
il a les lunettes de vant dam je sûr
qu'il a les lunettes de et c'est pour ça
que John a été appelé dans ce studio
aujourd'hui pour le doubler qui d'autre
est partant pour aller tout de suite
leur mettre une grosse pâtée moi je
double écoute ce qu'on appelle une bette
un renard unraque tout ce que tu veux un
hamster mais c'est un plaisir parce
qu'il est hyper mignon et il est naïf
comme tout tu vois il est vraiment
gentil il veut toujours faire le bien
être un Ranger c'est son rêve finalement
un homme avec un rêve en fait je suis un
LX bon d'accord un longx avec un rêve
c'est vous que nous voulons allez si
vous êtes courageux alors vous serez à
la hauteur tu n'es pas à la hauteur moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de plaisir à une scène
en particulier c'était une scène il y
avait que des onomatopé et on aurait dit
vraiment quelque chose de
[Musique]
sexuel moment le plus gênant d'Europe
dans le film tu verras ça pas normal
dans le film par qu' y a des explosions
alors que quand tu fais du sex il y a
pas
d'explosion si je fonce dans
[Musique]
il y a un moment où j'ai chanté de
l'Opéra pour la première fois de ma vie
et je me suis découvert un véritable
talent
[Musique]
ça
l'homme guérit
guéris génial oufissime de GO je signe
et je persiste on espère que film vous
plaira si vous allez le voir canâin
général canâin général la belette le
Robo et le gros et à très vite sur les
Internet les gars ah fait chierz
allez viens mercion salut